Democratic Representative Jerry Nadler
and the House Judiciary Committee
presided over the first day of official
impeachment hearings yesterday where
expert witnesses made the incisive
constitutional argument that orange man
bad orange man very bad we will explain
the expert constitutional experts and we
will explain why they think the 2016
election should be over turned their
arguments and the arguments against
impeachment all of them coming from an
unexpected source then Canada's Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau trash-talks
president Trump behind his back trans
activists in Washington accused cops of
killing their families and finally the
mailbag all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
for those of you who are not as expert
in the Constitution as all of those
experts that the Democrats dragged
before the impeachment hearings
yesterday I will just remind you that
the president can be removed from office
for treason bribery other high crimes
and misdemeanors and if the orange man
is very bad the people missed that part
it's not taught as often in law schools
anymore but it is certainly the case
it's actually a more egregious crime
than treason bribery or the high crimes
and misdemeanors orange man being bad is
the impeachable offense and that is
pretty clearly what the Democrats are
going to impeach Donald Trump over we
will go through the circus that took
place yesterday before the Judiciary
Committee we will go through the species
arguments of all of the Democratic
testimony and we will go through the one
expert who managed to pretty much shut
down their case but first I've got to
thank our friends over at brickHouse you
know that it is very important to eat
your fruits and veggies isn't it now me
if I were left to my own devices my diet
would consist of about 93% fatty Italian
meats and about 7% provolone but
thankfully there is a way for me to get
my veggies and my fruits through brick
house have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick unhealthy and
overweight between the food supply and a
sedentary lifestyle Americans are in
worse shape than ever so the team of on
staff physicians at brickHouse nutrition
created field of greens field of greens
so easy to use it's so easy to add
fruits and vegetables to your daily
routine without spending hours in the
produce section or hiring a home chef or
taking cheap supplements that aren't
going to do you any good field of greens
is made with real USDA organic fruits
and vegetables it also helps boost your
immunity by using antioxidants and it
assists
digestive health with prebiotics and
probiotics it is like having a doctor
and a nutritionist in your kitchen but
you don't need to think about anything
you just take one scoop one
scoop a field of greens delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables just
drop it in a cup of water stir it and
you're done also great for smoothies
that's I that's how most of my friends
like it for me I'm just like a purist I
want the fruits and veggies put it in I
don't want to think about it bottom line
this is real food this is not extracts
you will look and feel better it's just
so simple you know I want to simplify my
life as much as possible there are
enough complications if I need to think
for more than two seconds about oh I
didn't eat that vegetable and I got to
have this and this but no none of that
just one scoop it's in you're done go to
brick house Knowles dot-com you know
that's my nickname go to brick house
Knowles calm and get 15% off your first
order just for trying it out with the
promo code Knowles Kenna wles that is
brick house Knowles my nickname com
promo code Knowles Kenna wles alright
let's jump right in to the expert
SuperDuper expert testimony beginning
with Professor Pamela Carlin one one big
mistake the Democrats made at these
impeachment hearings obviously they're
gonna call their people they're gonna
call leftists they're gonna call
Democrats they're gonna call people who
hate Donald Trump alright we just know
that's gonna happen but it was a big
mistake on their part to call experts
who are so obviously biased who are so
obviously partisan who come across as
such hacks the whole point of having
experts show up to your impeachment
hearings is to give this patina of
credibility of non-partisanship of you
know we're just looking at the facts
here folks and that's why we have to
remove the president they just couldn't
do that they picked for their first
witness as partisan as hacky a a an
expert as you could possibly imagine
professor Pamela Carlin Stanford Law
professor radical leftist and Democrat
she wrote a whole book about how awful
the 2000 election was when Al Gore lost
she's an Obama appointee she was under
Obama working for Obama and Eric Holder
a very corrupt attorney in general she
was the US Deputy Assistant Attorney
General she's an outspoken LGBT
activists in Obama's DOJ she was a key
person to implement the redefinition of
marriage you look at her political
donations donates to a lot of Democrats
and she this is probably the worst part
for her credibility she called for the
impeachment of Trump two years ago so if
what the Democrats are saying now is we
weren't going to impeach Trump but now
we have to because he made a
long-distance phone call to Ukraine or
whatever the issue is with the Ukraine
phone call that doesn't hold up when you
realize that this law professor and this
democratic activist was trying to
impeach the guy two years ago she
actually said on camera on a microphone
that when she walks by the Trump Hotel
in Washington DC she is so disgusted
that she has to cross to the other side
of the street I was struck hey you know
I came in from the airport yesterday and
I got off the bus from Dulles down at
L'Enfant Plaza and I walked up to the
hotel and as I was walking past what
used to be the old post office building
and is now that Trump hotel which I had
to cross the street of course but god no
never never but as I was walking past I
noticed there's a no never
oh it's so awful I can't even bear to be
on the sidewalk in front of the hotel hi
I'm gonna be your nonpartisan expert
witness okay that not a lot of
credibility she actually as she's
testifying she said that she was so
riled up for the these impeachment
hearings that she didn't even eat
Thanksgiving all she was doing was
reading transcripts she was so hungry
not for Turkey but to ask the duly
elected President of the United States
you know I spent all of Thanksgiving
vacation sitting there reading these
transcripts I didn't you know I ate like
a turkey that came to us in the mail
that was already cooked because I was
spending my time doing this I was so
excited gobble gobble give me all those
Ukraine transcripts so in her blind
hatred of the President she made a
crucial error not just the Democrats
error in inviting her but her error
during her testimony she let her the
zeal
to impeach this guy her absolute disdain
for the president come out and cause her
to bring Donald Trump's
thirteen-year-old son into the picture
now the left loves bringing children
into politics they do it all the time
they did it with the the Parkland kids
after the shooting at Parkland High
School they brought these these
traumatized kids in and put them on a
pedestal put them on a stage put give
them a lot of money gave them a big
spotlight obviously they're doing that
now with Greta Sundberg the
environmentalist child from Sweden and
they're putting her on a stage and
they're giving her a lot of attention
and they they're forcing her right in
front of the media that's an awful thing
that is absolutely indefensible but
that's kind of their mo they don't just
do it though for kids who want the
spotlight Barron Trump has very much
shied away from the spotlight he doesn't
go on stage he doesn't want to be in the
media and this woman as she's describing
why Trump is so awful he's so awful
because he thinks he's a king he's so
awful because he thinks he's a royal she
decides to bring his thirteen-year-old
son into it big no-no what comparisons
professor Carlin can we make between
Kings that the framers were afraid of
and the president's conduct today so
Kings could do no wrong because the
Kings word was law and contrary to what
President Trump has said article 2 does
not even give him the power to do
anything he wants and I'll just give you
one example that shows you the
difference between him and a king which
is the Constitution says there can be no
titles of nobility so while the
president can name his son Baron he
can't make him a baron oh oh yeah all
right folks try the veal tip your
waitress I'll be here all week see you
later
the really egregious thing about that
statement is not that she brought the
president's thirteen-year-old son into
the mix she shouldn't have done that
it's just how totally lame that joke was
it was such a reach it was such a
stretch if the puns not gonna work just
leave let it go if the jokes not gonna
work just let it go you don't you don't
have to do that Melania Trump
did not like that line Melania Trump
comes out there she tweets quote a minor
child deserves privacy and should be
kept out of politics
Pamela Carlin you should be ashamed of
your very angry and obviously biased
public pandering and using a child to do
it and she's absolutely right and I will
say as somebody who goes on camera a lot
Pamela Carlin you should be very
embarrassed by how totally lame that pun
was if you're going to try to make a
joke in public like that and you're
going to workshop it and write it and be
prepared to give it it should be at
least 400 percent funnier than it was
that was a very very lame and also
inappropriate and she felt it was
obviously getting such blowback that she
came out and apologized for her earlier
remarks during the same testimony I want
to apologize for what I said earlier
about the president's son it was wrong
of me to do that
I wish the president would apologize
obviously for the things that he's done
that's wrong but I do regret having said
that Thank You professor that's not an
apology that's not how you do an apology
when you do an apology you don't say hey
I'm really sorry that I did this but
really that big jerk made me do it
anyway but anyway I'm really sorry it's
like an abusive husband doesn't doesn't
say oh I'm really sorry that I
physically harmed you I mean you did you
did burn the pot roast so let's try to
keep that in mind and I wish you didn't
burn the pot roast but anyway I'm really
sorry it's not an apology but even more
than that this wasn't a line that she
just came up with in the moment right
this was a it wasn't just some flippant
thing that she said she obviously had
thought about this it's such a weird
stretchy lame pun she obviously was
workshopping this when she was preparing
her testimony
she's probably workshopping it in the
bathroom mirror in the morning that's
fine people do that when they're
speaking in public but it wasn't some
spur-of-the-moment I'm sorry I got
carried away I don't know what I was
thinking she she said it I mean she
wrote it she planned it it was and then
she got blowback and then she had to
apologize so
really bad I think the worst part of the
day for Democrats in terms of their top
witnesses was this woman she just didn't
she didn't make the case for impeachment
terribly well nothing that we hadn't
heard before and I think she really
damaged Democrats credibility but it did
get a whole lot worse for them when
Jonathan Turley another law professor
came out and just absolutely wrecked the
whole day we will get to that in a
second first I got to thank our friends
over at NetSuite you know when you're
starting a business when you're growing
a business it's very important to know
your numbers the problem that growing
businesses have is that they've they've
got this hodgepodge of business systems
right it's true in almost every business
so you're starting up a business and
you're using this software to manage
your HR using this software to manage
your sales you're using this ax right
and they're not talking to each other so
you got this hodgepodge of business
systems and you just can't keep track of
your numbers that seriously prevents you
from growing that's where NetSuite comes
in very handy introducing NetSuite by
Oracle the business management software
that handles every aspect of your
business in an easy-to-use cloud
platform giving you the visibility and
control that you need to grow with
NetSuite you save time money and
unneeded headaches by the way time is
money
all right time is money and unneeded
headaches is money too by managing your
sales finance accounting orders and HR
instantly NetSuite allows you to see
your whole business control your whole
business right from your desktop or
phone that's why NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system all
right you're starting a business you're
growing a business it's very high stakes
why would you handicap yourself why
would you not go in with the very best
right now NetSuite is offering you
valuable insights with a free guide
seven key strategies to grow your
profits at NetSuite calm slash Knowles
Cana wles that is NetSuite comm slash
Knowles Keo wles
these guys are the best in the business
go over there right now download the
free guide you have nothing to lose you
have a lot to gain seven key strategies
to grow your profits at NetSuite comm
slash Knowles canna WL e S
the next guy they call it is this a
professor Noah Feldman Noah Feldman
somehow was even more leftist than the
last professor Pamela Karlin though he
didn't step in it quite as much as she
did
Feldman tried to play his partisanship a
little bit closer to the vest he's a
Harvard Law professor a big liberal I
mean he's gotten all sorts of plaudits
from the left-wing media and the
left-wing public intellectual sphere I
think that's almost a contradiction in
terms but his point Noah Feldman's point
is that President Trump must cooperate
with the congressional Democrats
impeachment probe he must cooperate if
he's not cooperating he's breaking the
law the job of the house is to
investigate impeachment and to impeach a
president who says as this president did
say I will not cooperate in any way
shape or form with your process Rob's a
coordinate branch of government he Rob's
the House of Representatives of its
basic constitutional power of
impeachment when you add to that the
fact that the same president says my
Department of Justice cannot charge me
with a crime the president puts himself
above the law when he says he will not
cooperate in an impeachment inquiry I
don't think it's possible to emphasize
this strongly enough a president who
will not cooperate in an impeachment
inquiry is putting himself above the law
now putting yourself above the law as
president is the core of an impeachable
offense because if the president could
not be impeached for that he would in
fact not be responsible to anybody this
is such BS with respect to professor
Feldman this is such BS but it's what
not only the Democrats are trying to do
in this impeachment inquiry or
impeachment hearings now it's what the
left has been trying to do for a very
long time the president not just giving
the Democrats and Congress everything
that they want is not a violation of the
law it's not impeachable offense it's
not putting himself above the law what
it's doing is saying that the president
is not subservient to Congress which is
a very important aspect of our
government our constitutional structure
says that we have three co-equal
branches of government what the left has
wanted to do for a long
time is have the president be
subservient to the legislature they want
the executive subservient to the
legislature just like you have in
Britain just like you have in a lot of
governments around the world you have
parliamentary supremacy that they get to
control the executive but that's not how
it works here we have three co-equal
branches of government this is an
important aspect of this whole
impeachment circus because what the way
that that will all work the way that you
can have these two co-equal branches the
president and the legislature is if
there's some role for the judiciary and
what the left and the Democrats are
trying to say is there's no role for the
judiciary whatsoever in the impeachment
inquiry but there is there's a major
role the Constitution set up a major
role for the judiciary that's why these
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
preside over the impeachment trial
should it get to that point in the
Senate there is a role here for the
judiciary and professor Feldman doesn't
want to accept that or admit that
because it would complicate matters for
the Democrats you have an incredibly
partisan impeachment going on right now
only Democrats and you know a couple of
their independent so-called
supporters are pushing for this no
Republicans are pushing for this the
Republicans are uniformly opposing it
the president has absolutely no
obligation to go along with this
ridiculous partisan charade because if
the Congress if the Democrats are
allowed to impeach the president over
nothing simply because they don't like
the cut of his jib they think he's a bad
president they want to ask him you have
in that case destroyed the separation of
powers you have destroyed the co-equal
branches of government
you now have parliamentary supremacy
congressional supremacy and an executive
that is subservient to them Feldman was
pretty good at playing his partisanship
close to his vest even though he was
making pretty pretty bad arguments but
he kind of lost it a little bit when in
his zeal to present himself as an
unbiased expert he told a lie he said
that he was a skeptic of impeachment
until he saw the transcript from the
July 25th phone call with Ukraine then
he knew that this president's
we got to go accept representative Matt
gates pointed out that that just isn't
true until this call in July 25th I was
an impeachment skeptic girl changed my
mind sir and for research right except
he didn't accept it so you hear him say
that very clearly to Matt Gaetz he says
I was an impeachment skeptic and then I
changed my mind
not true long before that July 25th
phone call professor Feldman was writing
op-eds in which he said the president is
committing impeachable offenses has no
bearing on whether or not the Ukraine
call was in peach Pillai she has no
bearing on whether the the earlier
alleged offenses are impeachable but
what it is to say is that Noah Feldman
has been pushing for impeachment for a
long time he's been pushing for
Pietschmann impeachment before the July
25th phone call came out and he lied
during his testimony a blatant lie a
demonstrable lie he lied and lost what I
would say is a lot of his credibility
then you had the boring guy we won't
spend too much time on him his name is
Michael Gerhart he's from UNC School of
Law Gerhard same thing orange man bad
got to impeach him the record compiled
thus far shows the president has
committed several impeachable offenses
including bribery abuse of power and
soliciting of personal favor from a
foreign leader to benefit himself
personally obstructing justice and
obstructing Congress our hearing today
should serve as a reminder one of the
fundamental principles that drove the
founders or founders of our cause of our
Constitution to break from England and
to draft their own constitution the
principle that in this country no one is
King we have followed that principle
since before the founding of the
constitution and it is recognized around
the world as a fixed inspiring American
ideal huh I'm sorry all right is he done
he's done speaking now okay that's fine
so same nothing terribly interesting
here and that's important because the
purpose of these expert witnesses is not
to get more facts the Democrats have
already made their decision they're
going to peach him for whatever crime
they can try to even
pretending committed the purpose of
these expert witnesses is to convince
the public and I think Gerhart's
testimony was important because it just
showed they had nothing was wasted
testimony it's nothing that that is
really being talked about I also want to
correct Gerhardt and the first lady
pamela Carlin they talked about how the
founders hated Kings
and Trump's not a king and the king is
basically like a tin-pot dictator that
just simply isn't true about Kings first
of all some of our founding fathers did
want a king Alexander Hamilton pretty
much wanted to make George Washington a
king Kings were not just tin-pot
dictator some in the you know Caribbean
or something like that there actually is
quite a lot to monarchy and there are
limits to monarchy and anyway it's just
indicative of how much they are trying
to oversimplify and misrepresent the
facts not only a bad president from but
even about history and the Constitution
fortunately there was one law professor
who gave testimony who in a very
measured way without the hysterics
without the emotion without yelling and
screaming and bringing in bear and Trump
about it very calmly wrecked all of the
previous arguments we will get to that
professor in a second we'll get to what
it means for 2020 specifically Joe Biden
will get to a whole lot more but first
you have got to be prepared and I want
to prepare you because you never know
when a natural disaster or a political
disaster I think we have just been
listening to a political disaster occur
in real time you never know when that's
gonna strike that's why you got to be
ready wise company uses the finest
ingredients and food preparation
technology to ensure optimal freshness
and flavor every single recipe is
created by a team of chefs and is unique
to wise companies it's really just a
tremendous product they combine both
dehydrated and freeze-dried ingredients
to get the best taste texture and
nutritional value the final recipes are
packed into durable long lasting
packages they are designed to keep in my
sure and a stop air seepage and to keep
your food fresh delicious and ready to
be eaten
even if stored up to 25 years this is
the key
is the Armageddon gonna happen in your
lifetime is the apocalypse is everything
gonna meltdown hopefully not I hope that
isn't the case but why worry why have
this level of stress the great thing
about wise foods you just go you get it
you put it in the pantry you don't have
to think about it hopefully everything
is gonna be okay
but when something terrible does happen
eventually if it happens you will be
ready you won't have to to worry about
it at all you just pull out that food
they have these convenient for serving
patch sizes that virtually eliminate
waste
they actually have entrees that are
ready when you just open it up in the
pouch pour in a little bit of water and
you are good to go makes being prepared
so easy this week Wise has extended its
Black Friday sales event go to wise food
storage dot-com to take advantage of
these offers that only come around once
a year and they've extended it in
addition to that if you text wise WI SE
2 2 9 6 9 1 you will be sent a $10
coupon code that can be used toward any
item on their website no no exclusions
that is WI SE 2 2 9 6 9 1 and as always
shipping is free from my listeners text
wise 2 2 9 6 9 1 for ongoing automated
text offers from wise company message
and data rates may apply visit wise food
storage comm for privacy and terms here
he is Jonathan Turley destroying their
arguments what I would caution the
committee is that these crimes have
meaning it gives me no joy to disagree
with my colleagues here and I really
don't have a dog in this fight but you
can't accuse a president of bribery and
then when some of us note that the
Supreme Court has rejected your type of
boundless interpretation say well it's
just impeachment we really don't have to
prove the elements that's a favorite
mantra that is sort of close enough for
jazz well this isn't improv
improvisational jazz close enough is not
good enough if you're going to accuse a
president of bribery you need to make it
stick because you're trying to remove
elected president of the United States
now it's unfair to accuse someone of a
crime and when others say well those
interpretations you're using and define
the crime are not valid and to say they
don't have to be valid because this is
impeachment that has not been the
standard historically this is such a
great point and it shows you the goal
posts constantly moving right they say
the president committed bribery then you
go out there and say no he really didn't
and you can look through the history of
ratifying the Constitution you can look
through exactly what bribery meant at
the time you look through what bribery
means today nowhere does what President
Trump did even come close to any
recognizable definition of bribery and
the Democrats say yes so what so what
were the Congress we can do whatever we
want doesn't matter if you committed
rivalry you say okay that's a legitimate
argument to make I mean it's an
illegitimate constitutional argument but
it's a legitimate political argument to
make that's fine but then don't pretend
you're impeaching him for bribery
because you're not and you're admitting
that you're not you're just moving the
goal posts by the way Jonathan Turley
he's not some conservative Republican
the guy is a liberal law professor he's
a professor at GW political Politico
called him a liberal law professor and
civil libertarian this guy called for
the the prosecution of Bush
administration officials for war crimes
okay he's no friend to Republicans he
voted against Trump in 2016 but even he
knows this is bogus and it's totally out
of line with historical precedent
Jonathan Turley testified during the the
impeachment of Bill Clinton this guy
knows a thing or two about the history
of impeachment he says this is totally
out of the historical line if you my
testimony lays out the criminal
allegations in the previous impeachments
those were not just proven crimes they
were accepted crimes that is even the
Democrats on that judicial that the
Judiciary Committee agreed that Bill
Clinton had committed perjury that's on
the record and they're in a federal
judge later said it was perjury right
that's the history by the way we haven't
used we haven't used impeachment a whole
lot which is why we've got to be very
very careful about this it's the only
the forced fourth time we've gone into
this with a president you had Andrew
Johnson and Richard Nixon than Bill
Clinton now Trump no president has ever
been removed from office through
impeachment because he was impeached and
then convicted it has not happened we've
got to be very very careful about this
thoroughly then goes out there and gives
the final best line of the whole day he
he summed up what was really going on
they met they mentioned that President
Trump has to be removed because of an
abuse of power
Turley turns it around and he says there
is an abuse of power going on your abuse
of power if you make a high crime and
misdemeanor out of going to the courts
it is an abuse of power
it's your abuse of power there it is
your abuse of power Congress you are
abusing your power your power of
impeachment here there was no basis in
reality by the way do you know who would
back up Jonathan Turley on this point
I'm pretty much all the points he just
made Jerry Nadler Jerry Nadler the guy
who's presiding over the whole
Democratic impeachment process Jerry
Nadler would back him up and he actually
did back in the 90s when it was Bill
Clinton who was being impeached here's
Nadler the effect of impeachment is to
overturn the popular will of the voters
as expressed in a national election
we must not overturn an election and
remove a president from office except to
defend our very system of government or
our constitutional liberties against a
dire threat and we must not do so
without an overwhelming consensus of the
American people and of their
representatives in Congress of the
absolute necessity they must never be a
narrowly voted impeachment or an
impeachment substantially supported by
one of our major political parties and
largely opposed by the other such an
impeachment with lack legitimacy would
produce the vissa venus and bitterness
in our politics
for years to come and we'll call into
question the very legitimacy of our
political institutions the American
people have heard all the allegations
against the President and they
overwhelmingly oppose impeaching him the
people elected the president they still
support him we have no right to overturn
the considered judgment of the American
people ding ding ding you got it Jerry
you bet absolutely right I wish that
Jerry Nadler was showing up to preside
over the impeachment hearings because
that Jerry Nadler had it completely
right and the current Jerry Nadler like
all the other hacks and his party trying
to impeach him are making absolutely
opposite and species arguments now we
will get to what this means for Joe
Biden big trouble we will get to Justin
Trudeau on a hot mic we will even get to
a transgender meltdown and the mailbag
first I got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube by the way this this weekend
in theaters nationwide this Friday you
can go and check out safe spaces Friday
December 6th
starring Adam Carolla and Dennis Prager
no safe spaces is in theaters it's
terrific movie I went to the premiere
here in Hollywood you've got to go check
it out Adam and Dennis take you on a
wild ride to show you the effects of
political correctness identity politics
and cancel culture the film takes you
through the impact on college campuses
big tech and Hollywood no safe spaces
argues that free speech is important to
a free society shows you how it's being
threatened what we can do to fight back
it is not your typical documentary it is
super fun it's got animation it's got
recreations it's got a lot of Adams
signature humor to to help all of this
truth be illuminated it takes you behind
the scenes at Shapiro's crazy UC
Berkeley tour and if that weren't enough
there's a little cameo from jeremy boyd
god-king the daily wire in there and
most importantly of all i am in the film
I'm in the film it's a little Easter Egg
for one moment you can see me see if you
can catch where I have in the movie it
is going to be really really fun so go
check it out
gonna be a lot of fun no safe spaces
rated
g13 in the theatres Friday December 6th
the way that you can go check that out
is no safe spaces calm slash normal
Skinner wles for ticket information and
theater locations it's gonna be a lot of
fun it's a really really good film so go
check it out you know what you get ten
bucks a month under dollars for an
annual membership you know I think we
actually just raised prices a little bit
so look it's worth it folks we're giving
you a whole lot of stuff me Ben
drew Matt Walsh we we've got another
Kingdom on there the third and final
season we've got the leftist here's
tumblr daily wire calm we'll be right
back with a lot
Democrats are really bungling this
impeachment thing not just the the
testimony but the fact that if this goes
to a trial Joe Biden is going to have to
testify
Biden's already saying that he won't
come to testify but then they're trying
to make the argument that Trump has to
go testify Trump has to cooperate but
Joe Biden who is a key figure in the
whole impeachment probe regarding
Ukraine he says that he won't testify I
think when they started impeachment
Democrats were convinced that buyed
wasn't going to be their nominee trouble
is all of the people they thought we're
gonna be their nominees have now fallen
apart so looks like it very well could
be Joe Biden if he's the nominee is this
going to be a disaster for them because
they're gonna dredge up all of his dirt
they're gonna dredge up hunter Biden
they're gonna dredge up all the
corruption the Joe engaged and it could
really seriously backfire for Democrats
which is why I think there's a chance
they don't even impeach him they don't
let it get to that level but it will be
a lot of fun if they do on the other
side of liberal politics up in America's
hat over in Canada Justin Trudeau was
just caught on a hot mic making fun of
the president this doesn't seem like a
huge deal but it actually does tell you
something about the world leaders and
about Trump areas so he says here's what
why is he late Trudeau says he was late
because he takes a 40 minute press
conference yeah yeah yeah he's talking
about Donald Trump it takes a 40 minute
press conference
I've watched his team's jaws just
dropped to the floor hahaha chatting
with Boris Johnson and Emmanuel macron
Trump comes out and naturally just slams
Justin Trudeau for this well he's too
fast and honestly with a nice guy I find
him to be a very nice guy but you know
the truth is that I told them out of the
fact that he's not paying 2% and I guess
he's not very happy about it I mean you
were there a couple of you were there
and he's not paying 2% and he should be
paying 2% it's Canada they have money
and they should be paying 2% so I called
him out of that and I'm sure he wasn't
happy about it but that's the way it is
look I'm representing the US and he
should be paying more than bang and he
understands it so I can imagine him I
can imagine he's not that happy but
that's the way it is two key aspects
here he calls Trudeau two-faced and he
says look it's the way it is I represent
the US this is why people love Trump
this is why people love Trump is because
every politician is two-faced
duplicitous sniveling stab you in the
back and Trump will stab you in the
front
Trump is pretty direct he doesn't hide
his disdain for people if they've
crossed him he doesn't play nice to
their face and then behind their back go
and attack them he'll attack them right
out in the open maybe people don't like
when he's that combative that mean but
they do like that he's blunt
he's honest that he'll he'll tell you
what he means what you see is what you
get and he comes out there and he says I
represent the United States love me hate
me I'm telling you where I stand
that is a breath of fresh air in
politics and it's it's manlier and it's
more virtuous I know it's odd to use the
word virtue when it comes to
thrice-married laps Presbyterian but it
is that is a real virtue and the more
sort of sniveling leftists try to try to
unseat Trump I think that that
difference is going to be really really
clear before we get to them
I have to mention this crazy story in
Olympia Washington last month the City
Council met and they were scolded
screamed at by transgender activists
even though the City Council was paying
tribute to them on trans Remembrance Day
the the transgender activists were were
furious anyway for some reason and one
of the activists a guy named Amy Hart
claimed that the police officers
shouldn't shouldn't be in the room the
very fact that they had police officers
there was an offense to transgender
people because they quote kill trans
families and make it unsafe to live
here's the meltdown and you are telling
me you're gonna light up City Hall to
honor black and brown trans women you're
gonna light up a city hall that has
police and police are a part of the
problem they kill my families they make
it unsafe to live I'm a [ __ ] suffering
in the conditions you create for us to
not live in this city I want to say that
I am a person that values hearing out
people's pain and talking to their
hearts and I feel like the people here
at City Hall they don't do that you [ __ ]
with people's hearts you create
illusions point of order I'm gonna ask
that you refrain this is broadcast live
out people's homes with families so I
get Emily's my point is like you know
you didn't care what I just said which
proves my point you're not listening to
my frustration and pain having to deal
with people like you who are worried
about what I'm saying instead of like or
how I'm saying instead of what I'm
saying obviously this is completely
insane what they're saying that the cops
are targeting transgender people and
killing them and making it impossible to
live there's just no evidence of this
whatsoever this is not true but I'm not
going to make fun of these guys or
attack them in any way because obviously
they've got a couple problems all right
they've got some if you're a man who
thinks that you're a woman you've got
some things kind of going on in your
psychology that mean maybe it's not all
quite
right right and how this would
traditionally have been dealt with by
society is with compassion with empathy
and saying okay they're there it's
alright you know get it out maybe some
therapy maybe what ever try to try to
ameliorate the condition
now however we treat this the fantasy we
treat the delusion we treat the insanity
as though it were reality that's the
trouble that's very disconcerting for
everybody it doesn't help them look
they've obviously got a lot of
psychological turmoil here you would too
if you were a man who thought is you're
a woman but to indulge all this means
you you you don't make it any better you
just have the fantasies and the
delusions become worse and worse and
worse and this is true not just on the
human the personal psychological level
this is true socially and politically as
well even when you get to a topic like
impeachment the more you indulge this
this madness orange man bad impeach him
at all costs which Democrats have been
saying since before he even took office
that doesn't make things better that
doesn't pacify people that doesn't unite
people it only gets worse and worse and
worse and you have to start believing
crazier and crazier things that there's
no legal basis for impeachment that the
president committed bribery except even
if he didn't commit bribery doesn't
matter anyway because we're gonna just
have to get crazier and crazier and
crazier people don't like that people
feel on edge people feel anxious when
you do that
we prefer order order is better it makes
everyone feel at ease it's the reason
why when you get online in a grocery
store or something people will wait in
line for 35 minutes but if someone cuts
that line everyone starts to lose their
mind because that order is gone there
doesn't seem to be any reason any sense
any logic we are at risk of losing that
as a society we need to privilege reason
logic order a measured society both at
the personal level like people who are
screaming and having a fit here at City
Council meeting and at the political and
social level maybe it doesn't mean you
you get exactly what you want you get to
fulfill your personal appetite or desire
or your political appetite or desire but
in the long run that is the only sort of
society that we're all going to be able
to live in comfortably let's get to the
mailbag in our remaining moment
from Alex dear Michael history buff of
the daily wire a professor of mine
recently gave me a gave a talk on the
book Guns Germs and Steel by Jared
Diamond the story cited is used as
evidence that the Europeans purposefully
spread smallpox among the Native
Americans by giving them the blankets of
smallpox victims do you know of any
other stories like this or is it an
example of a gross over generalization
by a left-wing historian any thoughts on
the matter would be greatly appreciated
thanks you know the stories of giving
Native Americans smallpox blankets are
exaggerated and they only happened in
limited circumstances but it did happen
I mean during Pontiacs rebellion right
after the French and Indian War the the
British did give Native American
belligerence smallpox blankets and I
believe it did work I mean that's you
call it an early form of chemical
warfare that's true but what what people
leave out of that discussion is the
warfare part of it it's not like the
Native Americans were sitting there you
know eating the corn on the cob and
being very peaceable and the British
came in because they're mean and wanted
to wipe them out during Pontiacs
rebellion the Indians killed 2,000
civilians 2,000 civilians men women and
children and they killed 400 soldiers
they were at war and so the British
fought back as they could by they gave
him the diseased blankets and hoped that
it would work and in some cases it did
work the narrative that the left wants
to present of indigenous peoples or any
sort of peoples that Europeans engage
with as totally peaceful totally naive
they had no idea what war was they had
no idea what conflict was it's
historically ridiculous but worse than
that it robs these people of their
dignity
all right the Indians had dignity they
fought good wars all right they they
fought pretty hard they were able to
kill two thousand people in Pontiacs
rebellion two thousand civilians and
four hundred soldiers and then the
British fought back against them all
right this was an actual conflict and
and to say otherwise
it just ironically it dehumanizes the
indigenous people in the Native
Americans which is exactly what they
accused the conservative
the British and the settlers of doing
all right from Brian I would love to
hear your thoughts on the
spanish-american war Thanks
we could talk about this forever as a
very important word that nobody
remembers and nobody talks about the
spanish-american war or the war of 1812
number of wars that get lost Korean
conflict
spanish-american war was very very
important the spanish-american war set
America on the course of empire so we
fight the war we get territories from
Spain Guam Puerto Rico Cuba the
Philippines all of a sudden the US has
an empire an empire that we didn't have
before the spanish-american war now this
had certain bad effects I mean I guess
you could ask would Fidel Castro have
ever risen up in Cuba if Spain had
maintained control over it well Spain
might've lost control at some point how
about all the corruption in Puerto Rico
right now how about the dictatorship in
the Philippines what would the effect be
on America if America didn't pursue this
Imperial ambition I think that's kind of
all idle speculation I don't think it's
really worth paying attention to rather
than engage in historical what-ifs just
look for the significance the
spanish-american war was incredibly
significant and a lot of our imperial
ambitions here can be traced back to a
lot of our Imperial circumstances can be
traced back to that conflict from Aden
as the resident papist how do you defend
the ideas of purgatory infant baptism
and the common wafer being used there
being the body of Christ from the
heretical god-king thanks for the
humorous and somewhat informative show
all right well in our last moments here
you want me to defend the Catholic faith
all right as specifically against my
boss who signs my checks okay great idea
thanks very much we do it all you know
we engage in religious discussions all
the time here because you've got the
Protestant god-king you've got the
lowercase G lowercase K by the way
important for this discussion
you've got the anglican andrew flavin
you've got the orthodox jew ben and you
have the papist me and matt walsh by the
way who's not in LA but we talk to him
too
very quickly purgatory you see purgatory
in scripturally in second Maccabees
where they pray for the dead why would
you pray for the dead if there it's
already decided where they're going
because there is some sort of
purgatorial period in place Matthew five
Christ tells us the judge will put you
into prison until you have paid the last
cent meaning you can get out of this
prison whatever this prison is Matthew
12 describes forgiveness both in this
age and in the age to come but if
there's forgiveness in the age to come
that means that there is some sort of
purgatory you also see this cognitive
imagery in first Corinthians and in
first Peter in the the image of the
purifying fire not the punishing fire of
hell but the purifying fire of purgatory
infant baptism we see that infant
baptism actually a fair bit in Scripture
Matthew 19 Christ says let the children
come to me let the children come to me
not just the adults who can make a
statement of faith Luke 18 says now they
were bringing even infants to Christ and
then in Colossians Paul says that
baptism has replaced the circumcision
circumcision occurs when you're a little
baby baptism cam 2 and in acts 16 you
see whole households baptized including
the infants it doesn't say whole
households were baptized except for
people under the age of 15 or something
whole households entirely so there's a
lot of evidence for that the Eucharist
the wafer as the body in blood of Christ
in Luke 22 Christ says this is my body
the bread is my body this is the
institution of the Eucharist John 6
Christ says my body is true food my
flesh is true drink this is a horrid
saying by the way because people run
away from him when he says this it's too
hard and he says will you run away from
me to Peter and Peter says to whom shall
we go Christ says I am the bread of life
unless you eat the flesh of the Son of
Man and drink his blood you have no life
in you and of course in Matthew 26 he
tells us to do it take eat this is my
body the language is so clear so precise
such an admittedly hard saying that it
would seem very clear and then how do we
know to interpret scripture in this way
rather than in any of the zillion other
ways you could usually the Protestant
argument
is Sola scriptura that the scripture is
formally sufficient to to our salvation
and and this is ironically not a
scriptural idea you can look in
Scripture and see that Sola scriptura is
not sufficient you see it in second
Thessalonians so you hear so then
brethren stand firm and hold to the
traditions which you were taught by us
either by word of mouth or by letter so
right there the Apostle says hold fast
to what we've told you by letter in
scripture being writing but also what
we've told you by word of mouth and that
gets to of course the institution of the
church and the authority of the church
which we see at the Council of Jerusalem
and many other places I think there was
a 3-minute defense of the Catholic faith
if the God can doesn't fire me I'll be
back here on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael knows this is the Michael no
show see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]